[Music]
hello to the the online world yeah it's
a pleasure to have Nick boma visiting us
from Eindhoven today nick has been
actually in in I think pretty much all
the big places in the Netherlands been
at CWI you've you've been at ABN AMRO
and and I'd hope it and that you do you
sort of getting getting the gamut and
enlighten also right Nick has done a
good deal of work on multi-party
computation as well as some quantum
computation work if you're interested in
that come let's talk later but in
particular is going to tell us about
work on efficient multi-party
computation for algebraic kind of
structures especially I think if that's
it Oh an appropriate description so
welcome thank you yeah thank you very
much Josh thank you for having me here
so I will talk about multi-party
computation research at the Technical
University of Eindhoven and we are there
in the group with Barry school Macker
Frank bloom and Neil surveyed so many of
the things that I will talk about is
joint work with them and the plan for
today is to present you M PI C which is
a Python framework developed mainly by
Barry Schumacher's for performing
multi-party computation and this
framework is not so much tailored to a
production environment but more as a
tool for research and a rapid
prototyping environment and then I will
talk about performing linear algebra
over the rationals in an NPC setting and
if time allows I will say something
about a comparison or secure comparison
but if there's no time and you're
interested in that please see me after
the talk
so let's motivate M PI C or MPC why
don't we why do we want to have
multi-party computation
at the following example let us suppose
that the US Census Bureau wants to
compute statistics over medical records
well in a world without MPC the
hospitals would have to send the the
medical records to the Census Bureau or
the Census Bureau queries them and then
computes the statistics that it wants to
compute but with multi-party computation
we can have a better situation in terms
of data privacy and namely the hospitals
can run a interactive protocol together
with the Census Bureau so that the
Census Bureau gets in the end the
desired statistics and by the way
hospitals and the Census Bureau agree on
what statistics are allowed to be
computable however the the Census Bureau
just learn nothing beyond this statistic
so let's describe this a bit more
formally or maybe forget the application
let's just talk about what MPC can do so
here we talk about three parties that
each hold a private input and the
parties want to compute some function
that takes these private inputs such
that no party learns more than what can
be deduced from her inputs and the
output of the function and so there is
an example we could be interested in
learning the sum of those inputs or the
sum and sum product as given there by f2
or or maybe even we want to make a
comparison but let's not talk about that
that yet in this talk and yeah well how
to how to achieve this so multi-party
computation comes in two flavors garbled
circuits and arithmetic secret sharing I
don't want to exhaustively explain what
especially the first type means but I
just want to say to the experts or I in
this field I want to scope
talk that I only want to talk about
arithmetic secret sharing here
well arithmetic secret sharing goes back
actually to paper by blackly and also
paper by Samir from the late 70s and
here the question is how can we share a
secret among several players well we can
do that with polynomials in the
following way we assume that we work
over a finite field here I've took the
integers modulo a prime and I choose the
prime strictly larger than the number of
players N and I choose a threshold
parameter which is an integer which is
strictly smaller than our and over two
and we are here targeting the passively
secure case which means that the parties
they follow the protocol but still they
try to learn as much as possible from
all the protocol transcripts now we
choose a random polynomial upto degree T
such that the polynomial evaluated at
the point zero equals the secret now you
can think of a picture in your head
which might doesn't make sense
completely because we are here working
over finite field so the dashed part
doesn't exist of course but in this way
we could evaluate the polynomial in
other points than zero and give the
evaluations so kind of the y-value to
the different parties and if we evaluate
that polynomial at enough places namely
t plus 1 points then those influenced
define the polynomial and allows or
allows the players to the parties to
reconstruct a polynomial and reconstruct
with that the secret by if you're
awaiting the polynomial at point zero
and on the other hand T evaluation
points they don't give any information
about the secret so this is the
threshold property
yeah I wanted to make the parameters
concrete here yeah so a bit of notation
so I used these double brackets for a
secret shared value so this means that a
is is from the finite field and the part
is each whole share of a and then I can
perform operations with those secret
shared values I can perform addition
which is actually a local computation so
there's no interaction required between
the players to compute the addition and
there is multiplication which is more
expensive in the sense that now the
parties have to communicate to each
other and the reason for this is is that
if you do point wise multiplication of a
polynomial then you end up with a higher
degree so you need some protocol to
bring back the degree to what you start
with and that is that requires the
communication so if you want to perform
computations with MPC in practice then
it's convenient to have some kind of
framework that helps you with
implementing all this communication
logic and and arithmetic over finite
fields so hence there are MPC frameworks
and here is a list of such frameworks
the first one was fair play from 2004
and since then there have been several
frameworks and and these frameworks are
are all for arithmetic secret sharing so
there are also garbled circuits based
MPC frameworks but I don't mention them
here and in this talk I want to present
to you em PI C which is mainly developed
by Barry Schumacher's from the st. open
and was inspired by v which is also
mentioned here in the list from
which was from our host University from
guys like at all so if we classify MPC
frameworks within arithmetic secret
sharing then we could distinguish
between library based frameworks and
domain-specific language based
frameworks so in a library based
framework the MPC functions are just
library calls and you can mix those
calls with prop or features that the
host language offers you so for example
if you need to compute Legendre symbol
then you just used the the feature
provided by some other library and you
can mix that with your MPC protocols
whereas there are also frameworks out
there who offer a domain-specific
language and the letter might be better
suited for correctness verification but
on the other end if you need something
that is already there in the host
language and you first need some way to
import that or make it available in your
in your little world with this specific
language
but yeah both approaches have have their
pros and cons but M paisius is a
framework of the first kind so let's
talk about how M PI C works under the
hood about the execution model so if I
want to compute say two products in
succession
I hear the e depends on the value of C
so first I have to compute C and then I
can compute e if I would do that in a
sync synchronous programming environment
then you basically have to wait till C
is available and only then you can start
computing e and because here a
multiplication involves communication
between the parties you have to actually
wait for this packets
to go out to the other parties and the
other parties do something and then sent
you the packet back before you can start
your next multiplication so this would
be slow
hence FIF introduced this and also MPC M
PI C uses the S increments model where
you create a task for an operation that
would require network communication and
it would immediately return you some
some objects that indicates that you
will get that value in the future and in
Python that is called the future or in
some other languages it's called an away
table but it's all part of the same idea
so you can build up a computation graph
with these futures and then at the end
await the future and get a result and
there's also notion of core routines
that you can map these kind of
operations on a single threat if you
want or on a thread pool but the benefit
of this asynchronous execution model is
that you can already look ahead and see
what it's coming and you can already
execute local work which you might need
in the future so for example if your
protocol requires a random bit you might
do some or you might require a pre
computation that you can already carry a
carry out so it's in some sense a hybrid
form of greedy and lazy execution you
want to be greedy in the sense that all
the local work that you have to perform
before sending out a network packet you
want to do greedily while all the work
that would come after the response of
your fellow parties that you schedule
lazily so you can push all kinds of work
on the CPU or you can make or keep the
CPU busy even though you are waiting for
work packets to arrive and this oh
there's a question please there's a
question whether we amortize network
traffic so whether we combined several
things in a packet yes that's also
methods that you can use and I I know
that v uses that for some operations but
I sorry M PI C uses that for some
operations maybe not for all but that is
indeed a technique that you can use as
well to make things more efficient but
on the other hand you could also say
that a network packet is quite small in
itself so also the operating system does
some some chunking there it's it cuts
the stream in in packets so as long as
you make sure that you fill that pipe
that that stream then you you gets that
behavior that you that you suggest
already with yeah there there is a long
lived connection between all the parties
yeah so this asynchronous model has
these benefits and so that you can keep
the CPUs busy however you need some way
of throttle the computation in the sense
that if you would set out all the work
that your algorithm is going to to
require at once then you might fill up
the memory if this this executor goes
greedily through your code say through a
long loop and and keeps setting out new
work and at some point you yeah you fill
up the memory so so you need to throttle
there that there is also a mechanism in
M PI C called barrier which is meant for
that purpose
okay there were some slides about the
theory of M PI C let's see it in
practice and for that I'm going to
switch to a different view
so here I am in a Jupiter notebook and
one of the nice features of M PI C is
that it can run in a single party mode
in in Jupiter and this is maybe a bit
counterintuitive because we do
multi-party computation then why would
you be interested in running a single
party mode well that is very useful for
for debugging purposes so it has the
same API so exactly the same script can
be run in multiple instances of Python
and of course you need some small
configuration file to tell at which
ports those different nodes are
listening so that they can find each
other but when you set that up you can
run exactly the same code as in this
single player mode and by the way if you
are in a notebook and you haven't
installed it you can install it by this
single line of code this exclamation
mark tip install and PI C so here I'm
going to import the package I'm going to
define a secret integer type and now I
can perform a computation so I can make
a value 3 make a value 5 which are
secret integers and compute the product
and this M PI C output will say that it
it reveals the product so so I open the
result immediately ok nothing happened
so far I created the set I or C I can
inspect what to see Z means it's a
co-routine object so that means that
here we were greedily so we returned
immediately but nothing happens I still
have to run that co-routine so let us do
that with this line and I get the value
15 ok now you might wonder what is going
on here because well you've multiplied
to the numbers 3 and 5 and it's 15 I
believe that but where is the randomness
because here there's only a single party
who inputs three and five and if you
would now copy this instance to say
three parties it would still be three
and five so the the parties would
actually share a constant polynomial so
that's not really useful well it is
useful for development purposes again
but we keep in mind that this is a
simplification because if you would
really use this in a multi-party setting
you would have to branch on the party ID
and the parties well of course inputs
different data because that's the entire
purpose of doing multi-party computation
that different parties have different
pieces of information but again this is
just a a nice simplification that we can
use to input values and then we can
compute with those values as if we were
computing with values that are
originating originating from a single
player well another example here is that
I can create a secret random field
element and this is happens to be the
random field element by the way I'm I
can inspect in what fields I'm working X
a secret charity need yeah
here we see that we have a a 64-bit
modulus and I can inspect more I can
inspect it the bit length of this secret
integer which is only 32 bits and that
again seems to contradict each other but
the reason why this bit lengths which
conveys the use usable bit lengths for
the user is only 32 bits because we have
this Headroom that you need for a secure
comparison operator well I've got
another example here to create a random
bit well this is seems to be a random
bit and also here I show an
implementation of a protocol that could
create a random bit so here I start with
creating a secret shared field element
then I open the product or the square of
that that fields elements then I compute
the inverse of the square root of that
Square and then I multiply X the
original random field element with this
inverted square root which gives me
minus 1 or +1 at random and then with
this small transformation plus 1/2 I go
to two bits
I even have here a small example of
comparison so I have two values one and
two and I want to compare them together
or compare them to each other and indeed
X is not strictly bigger than than Y so
I get a zero here if I would change the
codes then I get a one okay so this is a
small introduction let's now go back to
the second part of my talk why you're
doing such a complicated bit generation
ah really a benefit to that over show
the reader infield element the question
is why I generate a random bits in in
this fashion
and do you mean it's a question why the
random bits function is implemented in
the above fashion yes yeah let's take
that fly because I think it's a there
are several random bit protocols and
each of them have some some constraints
or
like what one one question is whether
you want to have perfect correctness I
think okay let let's take it to fine
okay the next part of my talk will be
about secret secure linear algebra over
the rationals and this is a joint work
with fan base who Marcus and Niels -
faded and I want to here scope the
setting I'm still in secret sharing
based multi-party computation and I
focus on the multi-party scenario with
larger or equivalent three players and I
assume that I have some arithmetic black
box at my disposal which provides me
with say an addition operate addition
operation and multiplication operation
and an opening values etc so I don't
specify exactly which MPC framework I
use I view it as an API that is there
that I can use and now my problem that I
want to consider is that I have a full
rank square matrix a and a vector B with
integral coefficients and all these
those entries are secret shared among
the parties and now I want to solve the
linear system ax equals B so I want to
solve for for X and I want to do this
over the rational numbers the rational
numbers to use the connect correct
pronunciation so what is the motivation
here I view the rational numbers as some
kind of approximation to the real
numbers and engineers usually want to
solve linear algebra problems over the
real numbers and if they come to the
cryptographers and they say hey we we
have some privacy problem we want to
solve a linear algebra problem in the
context of MPC well then maybe the
rational numbers are the closest
arithmetic structure to
to work over which mimics the reels and
we are interested in in data processing
applications or or secure statistics etc
if we look at related work then there is
related work by toma stuffed from 2009
who works over rationals in MPC in the
context of solving linear programs and
in the two party case there are some
some references mentioned there but well
I focus on the the multi-party case if
we think about performing arithmetic in
in a finite field in MPC and then think
about integer arithmetic versus rational
arithmetic well let's first say that
integer arithmetic is it's easily easy
to do so we have the correspondence
between the integers minus P over 2 2
plus P over 2 truncated or floored and
as long as we don't wrap around the
modulus we keep this correspondence so
we can perform additions multiplications
and it's as if we were working over the
integers when our prime is big enough
with rational arithmetic we could do a
division because we are in a finite
field and then the division would be a
multiplication by the multiplicative
inverse of B and as long as a and B are
small enough then there are still a a
correspondence it's just that if we
would look at this field element X we
don't recognize there anything human
right if you would defy if you would
compute 2 over 3 you get some humongous
field element and and with rational
reconstruction you can still reconstruct
these this numerator and denominator
memory by performing a lettuce basis
reduction you encode these
the basis as shown here on the slide and
if you run Lagrange grouse you will
eventually get back a and B the problem
however if is if you want to perform
this in a secure multi-party computation
you must be constant time or data
independent so you would have to run
this algorithm for the worst case and
pad it with with dummy operations and
the worst case was analyzed by receipt
valet it's order log P iterations where
in every iteration you would have to do
an integer division so division with the
truncation so that would be impractical
in multi-party computation so our
approach is is different if we look at
the problem of solving a linear system
well let's just invert the matrix
because we have a full rank matrix and
numerical people would never compute an
inverse but here we are doing exact
arithmetic so we don't have condition
and numbers to worry about and you can
think about the inverses the advocate
matrix of a divided by its determinant
where both of these objects like
etiquette and the determinants are over
the integers and so again if we have a
prime that is big enough we can embed
them in the in a finite field so this
representation of the solution prevents
the occurrence of rational entries and
with that we don't need the rational
reconstruction
so here we work over the the field FP
and we are going to compute the inverse
of a via a modified protocol from camera
and dumb guard which is in turn based on
body long beaver from 89 and in in this
common dumb guard protocol which was
rigidly presented for computing the
inverse over finite field there we keep
at all places to educate and determinant
separate and P must be large enough so
that we don't go get wraparound and here
that's easy to compute it's essentially
the how to mark bounds for that matrix a
and here or I call the matrix M where I
used the matrix a before anyway it's
this B is a bound on the on the elements
of that matrix and then that's the
column art inequality and word
essentially means here that I still have
to compute this product so then in order
to represent that product I need to
slightly increase P of course
well the protocol goes as follows yes
the determinant there's a question here
that asks if the determinant can get
large or huge yeah that is indeed the
case so we are doing exact arithmetic
here with which means that you have an
inherent size growth on the other hand
if you would like to do approximative
arithmetic or say floating-point
arithmetic you would have to first build
a floating-point computation in
multi-party computation which is also
expensive so it's there's a trade-off
there and depending on your application
you might use this approach I mean this
this works well for for small dimensions
and if you have say a prime of 200 bits
or thousand bits you can still handle
and those many cases but on the other
hand if you have a huge matrix there's
no way that you are quite well it will
not be efficient yeah because you have
this big growth and you need a huge
prime and making computations with that
big prime is heavy so indeed there's no
free lunch so the protocol goes as
follows and this matrix a has entries
that are a secret chart over the field
of B and we are going to sample a lower
and upper triangular matrix at random
where this L is actually unite regular
so it says has once on its diagonal then
we're going to compute the product of
this Ln U which we call R and let D be
the determinant of R and we can compute
that determinant immediately from the
diagonal elements of you now we're going
to compute the product of aren't a and
refill this product so we make the
product public and it's this art and
access a blinding matrix for for a now
in the clear we can compute the
etiquette and the determinant of a for
example with the black eyes algorithm
and then rear well remove the blinding
and and go back to the secret shared
world by multiplying from the right R
and the inverse of of the determinant to
get educate of ie and the determinant of
a is the is equal to the determinant of
RA times the inverse of D
and there's if you would compare this
algorithm to or this protocol to the one
from common and dumb guard making this L
unit triangular actually somewhat
simplifies the proof because in their
protocol they do not use a unit or
angular matrix and of course they don't
keep this determinant and educate
separate yeah this gives you a constant
rounds or constants runs protocol with
sqrt order N squared local local work
and here this n squared assumes that I
have a cheap inner product as Shamir has
a cheap inner product so that if I do a
length n or have vectors of length N and
I compute the inner product that's as
expensive as just computing one
multiplication because I can compute all
these multiplications in parallel which
is local work and I don't count it and I
just have one reshoring so one
interaction with the other players all
right now I'm I want to to show this
protocol how you can implement this in M
PI C so I'm going to switch back to do
my mirror screens to the browser
make it a bit bigger here and I'm not
going line by line through this
implementation but I just want to see
that if you are working on such a
protocol it's quite easy to to implement
it in this M PI C and check whether you
didn't forget something so here is just
an implementation in plain Python of the
the bias algorithm and this computation
is one that happens on public data
because it's it's run on this non secure
part of the order the the opened matrix
so well we believe that that is correct
implementation of my eyes here I wrote a
wrapper to be able to use some new PI
functions for example for the part where
we have to sample the random matrix we
are first creating this lower and an
upper triangular matrix and numpy
provides these handy functions for
arranging data at a certain way in a
matrix and I can reuse that actually for
my secret matrices because numpy well
has a parameter where you can specify
what the element type of the matrices or
objects should be so this is another
example of where an MPC framework that
is implemented as a library has a
flexible way of interacting with the
features of the host language which I
make use of here
so here well I create a random vector I
divide or I compute the the inverse of
the product of the diagonal elements of
the matrix U and here this M PC dot prod
does a product tree so it's logarithmic
depth product over a list so it's a
fault
over a list that is run in parallel
here I actually used the multiplication
operator from NIMH pi and I applied that
to the secret matrices but actually in M
PI C there is now also a a matrix
product operator
anyway this function gives me the the
blinding matrix R and this inverted
determinant of the matrix and then here
this is the actual function which is a
core routine and M PI C makes use of
async IO which is the asynchronous API
of Python and in in I think you know you
you have function definitions that use
the keyword async async' death and
there's also a decorator here which is
from M PI and PI C that does some
bookkeeping anyway here's the top level
script I have a matrix I secret share
the elements and then I I run the
protocol and I open the result and here
well we get the output and again this is
just to demonstrate that in a few lines
of code you can quickly implement the
protocol and see whether things work out
questions about this needs to be here
the question of snidely or did you have
to be careful with it Elizabeth
the question is how does my c-note the
modulus well there's a default modulus
that it picks if you don't specify one
and in this case we just kept the
default choice because it allows me to
compute up to 32 bits or even bigger
actually but only the comparisons are
limited but if I need a bigger modulus I
can just specify that so if you would
have an actual application you would
look at or find an upper bound for the
elements of a and then apply how to Mart
algorithm and then order the other mark
bounds and based on that set the the
correct prime or set to the bit length
of the prime
okay we have 15 minutes left so then I
want to continue a lot on person
[Music]
yep
so in the 80s there was Andrew Yahoo who
proposed the millionaires problem and
today you would call it the billionaires
problem and they want to know who is the
richest without revealing their account
statements but let's assume that these
billionaires are extremely paranoid and
they don't want to run a two-party MPC
protocol because they are afraid that
somebody else has a quantum computer in
this backyard and a text is protocol so
let's go to a three party protocol where
MPC can actually offer a quantum
resistant solution and here and the
Yahoo who's probably not a billionaire
maybe it's a millionaire I'm not sure
but he just runs as a third party as a
helper party so he is involved in a
protocol but he does not provide any
inputs and he does not to get see any
output but he's just there as a helper
party and Warren Buffett and Bill Gates
they essentially want to do a comparison
so you have two inputs a and B you can
subtract them and then determine the
sign of that the difference that would
be comparison and then of course you can
distinguish between a say the proper
Signum function where you have also a
zero here as output this is attorney
ternary output or you have the greater
or equal than zero function which has a
binary output and in this part of talk I
want to to evaluate the sign using
quadratic residue city so if you
carefully pick a prime then you could
have the situation where the Legendre
symbol coincides with the sign of
over a certain range around zero where
this this range minus D up to plus D can
be of size order L where L is the bit
length of the Prime and this idea goes
back to faith from 94 that used this
trick to to compute the sign of a number
in an interval minus 2 to plus 2 in f7
and more recently by you this was
explored for much bigger primes and see
how you can build a comparison protocol
from that and that's on a print that
that paper by you well for example for
the prime 311 which is by the way bloom
prime and because it's a bloom prime
minus 1 is it's not a square so we have
nice odd symmetry around 0 in the in the
Legendre symbols and here up to 10 or up
to 11 up to and including 10 we have
this correspondence between the Legendre
symbol and the sign of the numbers and
because of this bloom bloom property
things look the same or mirrored at the
negative part yeah so so this could be
viewed as as a way of determining the
sign of numbers in in a small range or
and we can use this idea also in M pi C
or in MPC I should say if we can
efficiently evaluate securely the
Legendre symbol and the multiplicative
the complete multiplicative 'ti of the
Legendre symbol admits the following
folklore protocol for computing it so
first in an offline phase we would
compute a random field element together
with its sign and then in the online
phase the X here is the input
we we multiply it by this random field
elements so we blind it then we can open
this product and we then can compute the
Legendre symbol of that see as a clear
text computation and compute it with the
secret shared sign of that pair to get
the results and do this in one
communication round there's one caveat
here namely that we cannot use this to
evaluate zero because then we would kill
here immediately the product and the
adversary can see that we input zero
there but let's ignore this for this
talk we have written a paper and of
course there we we do care about it but
here let's just assume as as if we can
compute the Legendre symbol securely and
not worry about this this zero that we
actually have to circumvent you want the
interval to be now there's question here
whether the promise to be ridiculously
large for or to end up with a usable or
reasonable interval and yeah there is
indeed this lock lock P so but III do
have a table at the end of the talk that
shows some practical values and indeed
you won't have an extremely large
comparison range or sign evaluation
range but still it could be for certain
applications could be interesting now
but let's come back to that later anyway
this is basically the idea of at all
and this your paper now the question is
how can we increase the range of course
we can just pick a bigger prime and then
we will get a somewhat bigger get bigger
range but the question that we posed in
this work is whether we can get a bigger
range while we keep the bit length of
the prime fixed and why would we be in
in that well there's costs associated to
increasing a prime well in this work
what we what we do if we look again at
this 311 prime then if you look at this
error so to speak
then whether the sine function is is not
such an interesting function right or
there's not much happening here it's
just a constant line only some
interesting stuff happens around zero
where you have the transition but here
you could actually peek at your
neighbors and and do a majority vote and
repair that that error and so you you
take the the sum of the Legendre symbols
of your neighbors and yourself then you
get in a range of minus three plus three
and then you would have to compute the
the sine of this Y of X and you can do
that with yet another invocation of the
Legendre protocol or you could use a
polynomial to to find that sign well in
this case we now have a we look at what
one neighbor at each side so let's say K
equals one and we have a window length
of length three in this example so 2k
plus one but we can generalize that and
have the following definition where we
define the K range of P well where you
take a bigger K and hence a bigger
window and you call D the largest
integer such that you still have
correctness for your for this this
method and we set de KP to zero if you
cannot find such such a D and with the
this definition we can now go to the the
table of some some examples here the
first column gives you the D zero of P
which is actually the the Fieger
style ring
and if you have a window length of of
three then you get this D 1 of T and if
you have a window length of 5 so you
look at two neighbors on the left on the
right you've got this D 2 of P and if we
look for example here at the 32-bits
prime where we get the range of 96 here
if we look at a 32-bit prime we get 3
fault improvements and here you have
already yeah an 8 bits
range plus signs or essentially 9 bits
so there could be applications where you
are interested in working with this low
or medium range numbers and if we go to
K equals 2 for 32 bits we would actually
be here is 458 so compared to these 0
that's almost a five-fold increase in
the range
well I've any trade-offs I mean can you
compute 5 dollars cheaper than one even
5 single ones there's a question that
you also have to increase the the local
work yeah that's that's true that's a
trade off you you still need to compute
those those Legendre symbols I'm not
aware of a method to to compute them all
together in an in a more clever way and
yeah but indeed you you you do have to
you have to do more local local work but
one example where it could pay off is
that say you you are on the embedded
platform and you you also have memory
restrictions so you don't want your
numbers to be too big because you have
to store them then maybe you can
exchange space for 4 time
different crimes using say three primes
that are taking the majority vote
another question here is whether we
looked at taking different primes and
then take a majority vote between the
results within those prime fields the
answer is no we did not I think you can
do that would be an interesting
direction to look into but also with yet
say the the setting in mind where we
usually work over a single prime field
yeah you would have to do things that
the between those prime field so there
there would probably be modulus
conversions being fought which are not
for free so we applied this this
comparison methods to if the evaluation
of neural networks and this is a
multi-layer perceptron from a paper from
2016 from corbeil vo at all which is 4m
NIST so here we have this handwritten
digit and we want to recognize the digit
and we want to do this or evaluated in
multi-party computation so how the
multi-layer perceptron works is well
it's a bit small here but it's there's a
matrix of parameters and the elements of
this matrix are minus 1 or plus 1 so
binary in some sense and you do an
matrix vector product where the vector X
0 is actually the image that has been
flattened to a to a vector and then
there's also bias factor that you add
there and here the non-linearity is
taking the sign so that maps well with
our work here and then you do these
matrix vector products and taking signs
through a couple of layers and at some
point you end up with a
factor of length 10 where each entry
gives you an estimate of say the
probability that's the that the digit is
that particular number
so the probability for that it's zero
probability for one etc and then you
could take an arc arc max yeah so we we
have implemented so have implemented
this in MPC and report on the results in
in an upcoming paper ok this concludes
my talk thank you very much and I think
yeah state within in an hour
thank you
[Applause]
so I have a question about the linear
algebra evaluation so you sampled some
random matrices L and U and then you
publish the L times u basically times
the secret shared matrix so is that so
can you prove that that doesn't leak any
information about history matrix there's
a question about the linear algebra
protocol whether the blinding operation
and then opening the blind it's matrix
does not leave sensitive information
well the answer is yes there there is a
proof and the proof largely follows the
proof from camera dumb guard but it even
simplifies a bit because we've got
notice you Neela you need triangular
structure on L and then it's it's as
easy as showing that there is an is a
bijection so that things do fine okay
and also so for for the determinant
evaluation so you sometimes need to
divide by by the determinant which is
because of this and holds those random
matrices kind of uniformly randomly the
determinant can be like a random number
in
finite field right so it's not
necessarily smaller than who to pee so
in that case can you still do the
rational reconstruction when the
denominator can be arbitrary there's a
question about the determinants and and
dividing out its determinants and also
in relation to rational reconstruction
and first thing to mention is that we do
not use rational reconstruction because
we circumvented by keeping the educated
and determinant separate so we never
perform a division that is non exact
maybe that's already answers question
yeah but otherwise let's take take it
offline anything further okay thank you
very much
[Applause]